THE NASHVILLE PREDAT
REBOUND.
VEGAS, THEY'VE STILL GOT THREE
REGULARS THE GLASS AND
ULTIMATELY CAUGHT BEHIND HIS
JACK EICHEL.
KULAK.HAT ONE
OVER THE NET.
NOW KANE, RUN OFF BY WHITECLOUD.
.
IT WAS GREAT DEFENSIVELY, WAS A
KEY FACTOR IN, BEING ABLE TO
LOGAN THOMPSON STEPPED IN THERE
AND PLAYED TERRIFIC HOCKEY FOR
MAKE THE GRAB
>> GOOD
STEPHENSON.
PACIORETTY SHOT, GLOVE SAVE MAD.
AS A RESULT, EDMOMO
SMITH.
BUT THAT'S THAT PRESSURE AND
RELOADING YOU LIKE TO SEE FROM
YOUR FORWARD GRURNG AND THE REB
MARTINEZ, PRIED IT FREE FOR
LOS
PAPA
TYSON BARRIE.
THAT WAS A TOUGH SAVE HE MADE
WITH THE LEFT PAD.
ALL THISEY'LL REALLY HAD SOME P
HERE IN THIS SECOND PERIOD.
SEQUENCES OF SHIFTIS STICK, RETS
ONE  ALMOST A DOUBLE PLAY OUT
THEIR HOCKEY CAREER AND GRIND,
AND THEODORE.
POPPED OVER THE STICK OF
>> THAT LITTLE STICK BY
THEODORE, RIGHTAT BIG PADDLE EF.
PUTS AWAY A GREAT CHANCE IN
THERE TIGHT
WRAPAROUND AND
MIKE SMITH RECOGNIZES IT, NOT
MUCH, WANTS TO TAKE IT RIGHT YE
LONG WHEN HE SCORES.
SMOTHERED BY SMITH.
REBOUND MARCHESSAULT IN FRONT,
AND PANNING ON IT BACK.
HE OPENED THE SCORING BACK IN
THE FIRST PERIOD.CECI.
NICOLAS ROY ON THE PUCUC A PICK
McDAVID TOO, A08 ON THE GAME CL
>> GREAT SPACE.
THERE'S NONE. IF
YOU DON'T YOU HAVE NOT.
DID HE HAVE THAT COVERED UP?